boulet care podcast special guest my guy
fat nick is in here you're welcome
what's up nick [ __ ] gordon thanks for
having me appreciate it i saw you say uh
you go through your hemothy
just just that whole spiel that i saw on
social media because i that was
hilarious your mom should have named you
hemothy you are him i'm him timothy him
duncan him duncan
um him jung ung
him jong-un it's a good one oh
that's a heater i was with uh playing
sparks three days ago when he made one
jimmy lev jimmy levine jimmy levine yeah
like hate me ivy my bet him ivy ivy yeah
that's a good one i like that all right
yeah well
he is here what you been up to man
nothing just in la bullshitting um
first of all congratulations because
from my understanding you're you're
sober now right yeah two and a half
years two and a half years sober um and
for a long time that was kind of like a
part of your whole thing was you were a
[ __ ] maniac with the drugs
like the drugs and the lean yeah like
blade like my whole like it was like a
persona yeah it was like it was like
your social media you'd be having cake
shaped as lean bar all kinds of xanax
cakes and
[Music]
it was a wild uh i mean it was like
crazy because like i felt like that was
as much as like your allure with some of
the outlandish [ __ ] you were posting on
social media in like 2017-18 like what
made you want to get get your [ __ ]
together dude honestly
after peep died i was still on drugs so
i'm not gonna lie because you were
really close with people yeah we don't
know i was friends yeah we were on tour
together like from the beginning
everything but i think once after he
died i was still on drugs but
like maybe like a year and some change
after i was like oh [ __ ] like bro died
people are dying like
realistically i can't be on drugs my
whole life like one day you're gonna
quit or you're gonna die and that's it
like you have to quit one day yeah so
i'm like why not quit now while i'm
younger rather than waiting digging
myself deeper and quitting later hmm was
it how hard was it man it was bad
withdrawals and all that my mental
withdrawals were worth in my physical
withdrawals because my physical
withdrawals lasted like what maybe like
a little over a month you know like
puking want to [ __ ] yourself you can't
eat you can't sleep you're sweating you
can't do this but the mental lasted
yummy and i still think like my shit's
wired different
not in a bad way when you say mentally
what do you mean like
like just like thoughts or like your
anxiety or like your depression states
or just like overthinking just all that
[ __ ] you get me like you just like
scrambled now my show's already
scrambled am i just like
[ __ ] yeah like what what at the time
like let's say your peak drug use what
all were you putting into your body man
dude honestly i was probably
drinking maybe like
a four a day which i don't think is [ __ ]
like i think we lean is the weakest
opiate
but then i was taking like maybe like
four to six or four to five blues a day
wow
that's crazy yeah so you were like uh
i mean that's like a a a
interesting state to just move around
and all day yeah i mean thank god like
at least for me i wasn't just like those
people you see just nodding out like i
was actually getting [ __ ] done yeah
cause you'll see those people even oh
yeah and i mean just hit me differently
i mean like yeah like if i'm tired i'm
going to sleep and [ __ ] but i can like
still function and go about my day you
ever have a
like a scary moment where you thought
you maybe did too much or there was like
a moment that was one day i was in my
house like um in my old house when i was
doing drugs i was drinking lean and i
was popping blues and i don't know what
the hell i don't know what the hell
happened i think i maybe popped one too
many and then my vision was like
closing on me and like everything
started warping and i literally had to
go force myself to throw up like weird
i've never felt like that
so i don't think i was overdosed i don't
know the hell it was but like the
craziest yeah like my vision like
started like tripping out like like i
saw my eyes just like clothing other oh
damn about a blackout you know it's
crazy because like uh
i mean as much drugs as you've done you
seems to be you uh you you dodged
getting that fentanyl batch you know
what i think fentanyl
started way more when i stopped when i
stopped it was started to hike yeah
because right now it's like it's people
yeah when i was doing drugs it wasn't
that bad like at all like i i can barely
name people who od on fat right right
right yeah now the fentanyl [ __ ] now is
like it's like russian roulette every
time even the coca that was crazy is the
cocaine is like laser that yeah it is
insane
yeah i heard i don't know if this is
true but i posted something about uh
berner was i had burner on the show and
he had said something about like laying
off all the drugs because of fentanyl
there's people in the comments saying
that
there's laced
weed now with fentanyl and i'm like what
the [ __ ] the [ __ ] is going on here i
don't i don't know that doesn't even
make sense
like i don't like you don't need to cut
weed you get that's what i'm saying
that's why i don't understand i'm like a
seven of which is like seven right
people yo man do you tell him the weed
is cooked with fentanyl i'm like how
does that make sense i don't make it
make sense i don't get it yeah no
because you're cutting your white right
to make it stronger way more you can
stretch more yeah but i need like a
seven a week so seven a week yeah yeah i
kind of think so
so um
did you find like when you got sober you
had to get rid of certain friends or
certain people in your circle um no i
don't think so because i think i was
very smart and choosing who i surround
myself with yeah i mean like i can
really name who's my friends in terms of
my acquaintances right but
it definitely
helped me to tell him like yo like you
gotta get off this [ __ ] or like
tone it down a bit hmm
like i still got friends that are on
drugs yeah 100 they're under [ __ ]
but like they definitely toned down than
what they were because i'm sure like at
a certain point in time your fans
probably also had to be like leaving
comments like bro chill out like yeah
they would say chill especially once the
the fat epidemic started but yeah i've
been clean i i haven't touched pills or
lean in like two over two and a half
years i don't smoke weed anymore bro
congrats don't even smoke weed i get
panic attacks like back in the day i can
smoke ass
now i smoke panic attack panic attack
crazy congratulations man i vape you do
some vaping a little bit of that liquid
tobacco yeah yeah if you blow them
circles you see on youtube there's the
[ __ ] these guys in [ __ ] fox racing
shirts and cargo shorts they blow these
huge ass spots i got the big brochure oh
hey man you'll take it right
i mean it'll kill you slowly but then
yeah everything's gonna kill you
everything's gonna kill you man that's
dope man well [ __ ] are you do were you
ever a big drinker of alcohol dude i've
never been drunk in my life i've been
tipsy right
like
i've never drank but now i'll go out and
i'm like social drinking i mean like
obviously that's great yeah i won't get
drunk or anything dude congrats man
that's a hard thing to shake especially
when like you have a persona that's
known for so much of that did you find
it hard to like
kind of have an identity in the music
[ __ ] that wasn't being the big dude with
drugs and guns now you're just the big
dude with guns
i mean i mean definitely i think that's
what like definitely brought a lot of
attention right because it was like like
i said when soundcloud started right i
feel like that brought a lot of
attention because it was a whole
different era of rap and a whole
different era of everything because back
in there was like
club music you got to look a certain way
you got to do this and then boom
soundcloud and then there's like
a thousand different characters right so
i do think that helped it and not just
that but the drug gun was definitely
like a wow factor you were a part of the
era of
uh hip hop that i like to call the dark
age
i always refer to this age of like 2017
2018 where
a lot of [ __ ] and i'm you and poo i
always have been a fan of you and puya's
music uh i think putin rap is i mean
he's [ __ ] incredible but you guys are
a part of an era of music
that i do feel like
was fueled a lot by antics
on ins and i'm not saying you in
particular yeah but you know what i mean
like i think of lil pump and i think a
lot of these guys who literally kind of
came out of that era of music and a lot
of it was more based on what they were
doing on their social media
not to say pump wasn't doing numbers or
but there was some guy like what's that
guy's name who said he was a clone
damn i know exactly what you're talking
about oh kitty boo kit kid boo right is
a perfect example right like his music
wasn't very good his entire spiel was
this wild [ __ ] he was doing on his
instagram page and he got signed to a
major label like i think island or
somebody actually gave him a wrecker
contract right
and i just think of like those kind of
guys where it's like that was the era of
hip-hop like and you were doing your
thing prior to that
you know like i said i lived in florida
when you and puyo were coming up y'all
had it lit as [ __ ] yeah but once that
[ __ ] kind of hit the mainstream i say
2017 2018.
man it was so much [ __ ] getting
pushed
but there's people like i don't know bro
right i think i might have met him one
time so it seems like i've met him he's
a nice guy but there's people like
soundcloud got very oversaturated right
and there's people like that who maybe
blew up but it doesn't have a cult
following
and then they just like
you can't really do much after then you
have people like puglia or pomp or
suicide boys right who have a father and
well also the music yeah and the music
too and you have a cult following you
can go sell out shows you can go sell
out merch you can go do this you get me
so i definitely think it's like a
there's a lot of clutter in it but the
ones that made it like you can
definitely no i think suicide boy is a
great example right they're still going
crazy you guys there's something i
should do they're on tour right now like
seven thousand thousand people no for
sure i don't want to discount everybody
from that era i just know that like
like you even mentioned little pump pump
at a certain time was like the hottest
rapper in the world yeah but i do feel
like he [ __ ] up
where he wasn't focusing as much as
making great music as he was focusing on
antics and a bunch of other [ __ ] and
it just i like it like we saw it with
our own eyes like his [ __ ] just started
to go like down and it was like and he
was like doing a bunch of desperation on
instagram i felt like for like
likes and [ __ ] and i was like bro like
just put out some [ __ ] good music
because pump had great records
he's good i i [ __ ] with him yeah yeah i
mean you know i do agree which i think
he was like harder at one point right
but i just think and then you would see
him like grasping at like
just what wild [ __ ] can i do on my ig
whether it was his nails or do the trump
it was just a lot of [ __ ]
but
like you said there were there are
people who from that era cut through who
are real fan bases yeah who and i think
you guys are that like suicide boy is a
great example you know what i mean so
but i do
i do feel like
i mean not no offense you guys are from
the worst era of hip-hop
um
all right i'll be honest
it's like rock music right you have rock
and then you have branches you have punk
you have metal you have this you have
that you have gen and then you have hip
hop which is like the soul root but then
you have trap you have rap you have this
you have this you this i don't like hip
hop music
i think you are i think you make rap
music then it's good yeah it's like rap
music so i don't think it's the i don't
think it's the worst i'm not saying you
guys i'm saying that just the era of
like everything that came out
dude i think supreme patty might have
got a record deal in 2018. i i think he
did like this is what i'm talking about
like
if you had gone viral on academics
enough like these stupid ass [ __ ]
labels were just handing anyone a
[ __ ] check oh that's just labels
trying to make a bag and seeing what you
know but that's what i'm saying i mean
like that whole that's why i call it the
dark era because it was like for a solid
two years
most of what it was about wasn't the
music and now it's always
not always about the music but i feel
like in that you know two three year
span it was it was rough
because i'd have people coming up to
show i'd be like god do i what is going
listen no disrespect to kid boo because
i don't want to keep coming back to kids
but that was one where i was like me and
had interviewed him and like he started
tagging up his shoe in the middle of his
gucci shoe and he put it on his head and
i was like oh this is what we're doing
okay so all right the music's not very
good uh
all right well yeah you're a clone okay
i know that's
like like in that situation that's just
like reaching for you yummy so you can't
you can't be corny there was a lot of
that [ __ ] though i'm not saying it was
it was i mean and like i said like you
said man like a good example like right
now suicide boys are on tour killing it
um and there was like people out of that
era that were like
puya you know um
shakes dope uh you know germ was dope
like there were some dope dudes but like
i said like i just think that
when i think of like
the rappers that came out of that era
i just think it's the worst ever
um i i can go back and forth i do okay
there's more shitty ones than good ones
that's what i agree with that's what i
mean okay yeah that's what i mean yeah
and i'm not saying you're a part of the
shitty oh no no yeah yeah
but you're a part of the dark ages
i do think though
that
it did when the generation started it
was very influential to like for sure
chief keef i don't think he was enough
gets enough flowers of course keeps like
probably one of them i mean listen
everyone we interviewed who's
maybe 25 and under that's usually who
they name is their influence yeah i
think he
created a not created but influenced a
whole genre for sure
no chief keef's probably
top five most influential rapper ever
100 and there's a bunch of 40 year old
white dudes with [ __ ]
camouflage pants and timberlands on
right now like [ __ ] that it's not real
rap bruh
but no you're right not chief and and i
don't put chief keith in that you know
but nah i think the whole soundcloud
area in general like the cream of the
crop influenced
a whole era of music like think about x
right like x started off on soundcloud x
started off with his music not being
mixed and mastered and it was over
modulating and it was hard to listen to
in the car because it would like break
your speaker but
kids loved it he's like my son's tupac
you know what i'm saying and he
influenced so
much of what's going on he influenced
juice world who's kind of a branch from
like the x world you know what i mean
yeah
yeah i think the soundcloud [ __ ] like
with anything like there was positives
and negatives and
you know but it was just a goofy-ass
time in music where these labels were
trying to find there's a very different
time that's never been seen before a
hundred percent a hundred percent and i
feel like when labels saw they're like
holy [ __ ] let's sign everyone everyone's
[ __ ] watching everyone was trying to
find the uh
their little pump yeah so they're gonna
sign 15 people and out of that fifteen
one one of them makes and that one's
going to recoup for everybody yeah yeah
that's real that's real did you ever um
because you never signed to a major
right you stayed independent this whole
time yeah i'm sure everyone was trying
to sign you i mean yeah i've had
interview interviews i had a meeting
with a bunch of people but it's like
i don't think it's worth it yeah yeah
what what was um for you why why
did you and puya kind of make that
decision to stay indie
so when you first started making music
right it started popping off right and
obviously you monetized it on tunecore
distro whatever right
yeah all that [ __ ]
we started making money here
we went on tour we literally called
cities
all around the country and booked venues
ourselves like we booked the venue no
booking agent no booking agent at least
when we first started booked the venue
whatever they wanted boom sell it out
make the money so when we got off tour
we're like yeah we're making money like
real money our streams are kicking in we
just made x amount on tour and we made x
amount selling merchandise on tour so
when we would go to meetings and they
would want x percentage would be like
why are we going to give you a
percentage to not guarantee it because
the label can't guarantee you you should
can't guarantee you anything they can
promise you but it's not that's not the
only thing they can guarantee you is the
amount of money they give you up front
and that is the back door for them to
[ __ ] you in the end yeah so it's like so
i'm gonna take that
hopefully you can do something for me
but i still gotta recoup that and you're
still gonna take like 50 or 60 yes trash
which is insane so i'm like we're good
like i know how much money i can do
merchandise i know how much i get per
show and how much i get streaming so i
don't really need you unless you come up
with something crazy that makes sense
for me
yeah like i agree with like distribution
deals and stuff that's cool these are
cool like if it's in your favor and
stuff
uh yeah no i think that
you guys had the right i think the worst
thing people do is sign too early or
sign at all sometimes yeah and i
realized that during coven because i
follow artists right and they're
complaining about their deals or yeah
it's just the [ __ ] live money dried
up and they're not seeing any actual
money from their music because they
haven't recouped yet yeah so it's like
that's a main key reason and they blew
through their advance and that's all the
money they got coming in hey if you
ain't recouping there's no more money to
see from your music
you know you better recoup so that's why
andy's the best bro you literally get a
good agent
get a good publicist have a good home
your manager and i think you're chill
yeah i mean you um
you obviously work closely with the
rolling lao guys and they've been
booking you from the jump when they were
just dopey and t um
what is your relationship like with
tariq and man those guys dude i love
tariq i love matt matt's like my goddamn
dad yeah i mean like he's like uh a
different dimensional dad for me i love
kelvin i love everyone from there you
got me they're definitely family i think
they're really in tune and hip with the
culture and they really know what's
going on too like i mean they've always
been that way right so like they've been
throwing the shield in florida since
before rolling loud all the rap shows
were like going through everybody they
were doing everything yeah before
rolling loud it was like
that was it yeah it was they were doing
the whole [ __ ] state miami they were
kind of the only people bringing like
real rap shows to my miami orlando tampa
and i think jacksonville too yeah i
think they started booking currency too
like yeah they ever did yeah which is
crazy to think damn
i'm old man but
um you were saying that uh off the
camera you're you've been doing like
some tick tocks going to food places
yeah right but there's kind of a more
official play happening with you doing
like a a food type of show with
collaborating with rolling loud yeah so
mean rowing loud we're doing a food show
right so we're going to different
cities states whatever we're eating
cooking with the chef cooking with the
cooks raiding the restaurants talking
about it's history and all that so it's
tight real episodes is it kind of like
what action bronson did a bit um
uh i would i love bronson hats off to
him i love that guy yeah um
guy fiori dino diving and drive type
thing
yo by the way shout out to him he lost a
lot of [ __ ] weight man
you lost some weight dude i was on keto
i was like i'm on keto right now dude i
was that [ __ ] works i was three four
this [ __ ] fat [ __ ] on the couch bro i
was 340 pounds i went down to 260. i was
wearing an extra large shirt
i [ __ ] it up i went back to 320 and
today right now i'm 305. but keto
brumped i was 260 on keto
for this guy did keto for like three
days he was like bro i cheated i'm like
bro that's not how this works i did keto
for four months and lost 60 pounds
wow cook
dude i swear to god super easy rolling
now you can you could eat cheese you can
eat all kinds of bro there's tortillas
now there's tortillas mr tortilla in san
fernando one wouldn't that grand per
tortilla bro i would all day i'm making
you know those uh philly cheesesteak
meat yum yums that you buy like
dude i'm making philly cheesesteak
burritos all day i'm eating like maybe
15 carbs a day dude
yep it works bro i'm back on it right
now and especially with this food show
like when i'm not doing it i'm on keto
i've lost weight 20 pounds in a month
right now like i'm on keto right now
the [ __ ] is legit you go to the [ __ ]
costco they got keto bread yeah that's
what i be eating they got all kinds of
keto [ __ ] even like this so like i like
cooking right so i'll make chicken parm
right yeah and you know chicken parm is
breaded right i have breaded i'll get
pork rinds and i'll grind up the pork
rinds and i'll put the chicken in the
pork rinds because you can eat pork
rinds on keto wait so you have pork rind
breaded chicken parm
it's gas
that sounds fine
i gotta tap in you got yo you should do
a keto cookbook no i should have cut
that book i was thinking about it
because i was thinking about different
ways to market my food our food show i'm
like yo i definitely do a cookbook after
dude if you did like a keto even if you
just did keto recipes on your youtube
because i think like there's not enough
of that on youtube for you know a lot of
the [ __ ] that you see uh when you go on
youtube for keto [ __ ] it's a lot of just
corny [ __ ] like hey like hey
guys what's up uh man you know how you
talked about um the dark era of rappers
bro right now with tick tock shout out
tick tock i [ __ ] with them but all those
cooks and true taster this is the
darkest area because i don't trust 95
percent of them and i think all their
taste buds are dog [ __ ] of course they
are you see like jason derulo goes viral
just for just throwing a bunch of [ __ ]
in a bowl and freezing it and then i'm
like you're not even eating that you
don't even believe that's good you're
chiseled like a [ __ ] statue
you're not eating all that sugar you
yeah anyway yeah no you're right about
that yeah yeah so when is the show going
to debut because you're about to go you
say you're about to do some a bunch of
episodes in new york yeah we're about
loud weekend we're about to be in new
york rolling a lot of weekend i think
the october 24th yeah so we're about to
film like i think like 20 episodes and
then we already have episodes done right
we're just waiting to figure out a day
to drop it is it just going to drop
through rolling loud or through dsp or
netflix we're figuring it out right now
there it is but definitely when we
figured out where we'll announce it um
talk about your relationship with peep
man because i know you guys toured a lot
together i mean obviously you got the
tattoo i know that it hurt you a lot
when he passed yeah so that was
why did i meet him a long time ago right
so my homie mikey was my producer my
best friend
he played his record in the studio and
he was like yo check this guy out and i
was like ah show me more you got me like
let me get into it so he showed me more
like oh this kid's tight
and then i think i'd hit him up on
instagram
and then we just clicked and i thank you
to ellen i met him and then we came
friends we went on tour together it was
me
peep smoke perp
and then yeah we just kept connecting
ever since wow the whole time we met
chill a few months went on tour yeah you
guys uh
you know i think peep is like one of the
i can't even imagine
where he'd be at
now skype is one of the most and not
even saying that that's my brother i in
this generation he is one of the most
influential people because i think of
like where a lot of music is gone
uh and
that was like the kind of [ __ ] he was
just already doing right yeah 100 even
from big records now from big art like
it's definitely from peep or an
influence i could have been a you know
you know i think like mgk right and
that's my guy but you know mgk's making
rock music now like i'm like man
people would have had that whole lane
just on lock like you know what i'm
saying like even like shout out to juice
world you know juice world did a lot of
that kind of [ __ ] and i think juice will
obviously rest in peace a legend but i
definitely think people was like ahead
of his time i did i would i was a jews
because he was living out here and we
were in the studio he was like dude i
love peep yeah i listen to people all
the time yeah no peep i think it it's
it's you know
it's one of those guys who
before he was even commercially known
like he had like a cool following and
it's like who would have known what
would have happened you know what i mean
yeah i think if he was still alive 100
one of the biggest artists well i i do
think he's a huge artist but he would
have definitely been like running he
would have transcended yeah yeah yeah
it's a whole different world that he
didn't even realize hey what up man we
got to interrupt the interview real
quick to tell you about our family at
odd socks now when i be riding for odd
socks so hard man it's because i really
love the product they got the most
comfortable socks in the [ __ ] world i
got a pair of odd socks basics on right
now go get those they got the socks wwe
joints you know i'm saying shout out to
the undertaker pepsi [ __ ]
really whatever you need some weed socks
nickelodeon but really they got the
draws now ladies and gentlemen
i'm holding a pair of tapatio underwear
right now you want some pop tarts on
your dick
pop tart draws and these [ __ ]
are so comfortable
like
man so listen you gotta go to
oddssoxofficial.com
and use the uh promo code the discount
code bootleg kev
at oddssocksofficial.com you'll save 20
off underwear the most comfortable socks
in the world crazy licenses not only
they got the wwe they got the scarface
they got the street fighter they got the
nickelodeon they got it all so make sure
you hit that website odd
socksofficial.com
save 20 off with the promo code bootleg
kev all right go do that shout out to
odd socks let's get back to the
interview are you and puya still still
you know besties you guys yeah we're so
bad dude i'm with him in l.a right now
we're staying at the same airbnb that's
amazing we're still bad we met like 8th
grade we're still super close you got me
like obviously he had to go do [ __ ] for
his career i had to go do [ __ ] for my
career but
yeah i think you guys are like uh
how you guys haven't done some sort of
like reality show or something or oh man
so
dude when we first moved there's stuff
on youtube and stuff but yeah because we
did a [ __ ] show yeah but when you first
moved to la maybe like 2017 we were
young as [ __ ] or 2016 maybe even younger
i don't know
we were presented a reality show
with some major people but we were like
no i don't know yeah because they wanted
to script it yummy yeah like maybe like
keeping up with the kardashian type
robin big dude but they wanted a really
scripted drama and play with like uh
sounds kind of
corny yeah we would want something that
we have more creative control over
um
do you guys ever did you guys ever ever
end up following up
um the what was the dropout [ __ ]
album where you guys stand in front of
your high school jump out of school did
you guys do with part two for that yeah
we dropped it at the beginning of this
year um
like what
what is like
you know when it comes to you guys
making joint albums you guys kind of
stylistically share a lot of traits but
as rappers you guys are very different
right so like when you guys work
together on music
for a project like one of those like
what how do you approach it differently
because your [ __ ] is very like
you guys meet in the middle i think a
lot but you guys stylistically oh it's
very different yeah very different like
his new album like it's all like
instruments like he's actually like
rapping rapping like we make very
different music so how's the compromise
when you guys come together
dude honestly
we'll just be in the studio and probably
go show what the [ __ ] you're doing so i
show you i like this this this this and
that yummy
and that's it yeah that's it like i
don't try to rap any other way he didn't
have to try to rap any other way like
i'll usually pick the beat
and write something and he'll be like i
like this i don't like this and then
we'll go from there i just saw you
posted on ig uh the first artist signed
to your your your your you have a label
yeah we both have separate labels okay
what's your label called young rich and
handsome entertainment is that what
there you go yrh yeah
i always thought that meant young rich
hispanic
because you know what the migo [ __ ]
means yeah
but uh i don't know i'm an idiot clearly
uh well i'm hispanic shout out to all
the peruvians and everyone else out here
um
yeah i saw you just signed an artist but
um
the the the kid that take a kid was
supposed to sign with you right so the
whole story with that right is i met tk
through
puya's dj marcus right he's like yo
there's this artist from texas blase
blasey is lit puts me in contact with my
[ __ ] with him he shows me the video so
i'm like yo you're hot like you're just
hot bro like i know my [ __ ] i've called
out multiple [ __ ] artists
so he had gone somewhere i didn't know
he was on the run i didn't know [ __ ] yes
i'm like all right cool i'm gonna sign
you blah blah
and literally he called me a few days
he's like yo i'm gonna come to miami i'm
like okay cool i'll buy your ticket let
me know he's somewhere up north or some
[ __ ]
so the day before i buy his ticket
literally he gets picked up by i think
was the us marshalls or some [ __ ]
yeah and then someone from his camp
sends me the video he's like yo take him
once you drop this video
and that's how the race ended up on my
youtube but take it was going to kind of
my aiming i was going to sign take it
and that's what not just some [ __ ]
you're just like part of buffet boys do
you mean yeah yeah
so
that's that's a crazy story man so
that's how that ended up on your youtube
page yeah did you ever actually meet him
in person never
when he was going to fight in miami i
was going to meet him he got picked up
by the marshals
wow and then you upload the video the
video goes [ __ ] crazy
do you guys still talk
i haven't talked to him in so long
yeah not because of my choice right just
because other people like plus it's not
like you guys are like super close
yeah
well so what the yo the buffet boy [ __ ]
is so fire to me i mean the merch
everything i mean thank you is that
something that uh
i mean are you still pushing the line on
the buffet boy [ __ ] yeah we still do it
you got me like well i like
i mainly focus on my merch mainly focus
on his merch but every other month we do
drop
buffet boys merch and then we just flip
it from there
what what is uh you you said you you
spent most of pandemic in a strip club
because you live in florida
florida good place to live best state
best state to live during the pandemic
for sure you know what i've i've
traveled the world like two times maybe
i'm gonna sound biased but i love
florida i love it too but
definitely south florida is way
more lit i'm like trust me yes the only
thing about south florida is just that
man i got off that plane a couple weeks
ago and that humidity it hit you in the
throat yeah it sucks the humidity
there's eyes but outside of that this i
think i mean i mean it might be
underwater in like 30 years but you know
they've been saying that since i was
like a kid yeah that's fair but um super
lit definitely in the strip club eating
chicken sliders eating wings whole
pandemic did you get do you have you had
kovid i got it once
i literally got so i had a china tour
when was cove at 2020 right march march
2020 yep i was in china october 30th
2019. so he was out there i was out
i would now within chiang hai chengdu
um and like two other cities you'd be
touring some random countries you've
done russia before right yeah i would
every time i go to europe we go to
russia i have a really big falling yeah
you've got a wild following and some
wild plague like this motherfucker's in
russia it's lit so you say you've been
all over the world but like uh how was
how was it being in china because in
china they knew that this [ __ ] was going
on and at the end of the year at least
was there any sort of awareness about
there being a the covet [ __ ] going on
dude don't tell me [ __ ] no one told me
anything i didn't know [ __ ] and then
when i came back maybe like two or three
months after that
i had to cover it oh you had it so you
had it like at the beginning yeah i was
children i just lost my my scent my
scent and my taste for like a week and a
half i mean you're a bigger dude too so
that had to be you know scary
they say you get even bigger it's harder
you know i got a tough immune system i
mean clearly all the [ __ ] you put in
your body yeah it's like dude if that
didn't take me down i'm good are you
vaccinated
i don't know
oh man i i don't
i'm not i'm still figuring it out you
got me
so
not yet
yeah
yeah it's so weird right it's like
someone asked you that you're like i
don't want to say the wrong thing
because i don't know you can't talk
about it because no matter what you say
yes or you say no you're in the wrong
yeah
i mean i got i got the jab but i think
what's going on right now is crazy like
people getting shamed for not wanting to
push it in their own body dude honestly
this is my thing right everyone's
entitled to their own opinion 100 and
nobody's wrong with their opinion
but
be courteous to other people so if you
don't get vaccinated wear your mask and
be courteous to those people who want it
and vice versa don't shame someone for
not wearing it it has to be a mutual
agreement yeah i mean just be courteous
to everyone around you just be nice man
be polite [ __ ] are so like just
cause we don't agree on everything don't
make make us enemies
it's so wild bro like
especially living here and i'm
vaccinated but jesus christ [ __ ]
la it's just these california people are
so sensitive they're so full they all
got sticks up their ass boss you know oh
man
it's not just california because
definitely there's people like that in
florida you go to san francisco and then
you can't even go to a [ __ ]
restaurant without the vaccine
oh man it's definitely different
different times living in i don't know
how more people just don't have fake
vaccine cards there's literally nothing
to a vaccine card it's literally a
[ __ ] piece of
plain cardboard
like
make your own
[Music]
it's crazy like but then again if you
get caught with the fake one that puts
you in [ __ ] jail which is also crazy
yeah i don't know
has that kind of like uh impeded any of
your traveling or any of your show [ __ ]
um
[Music]
no i mean
my europe situation but that's just
because like kobe keeps going like up
and down apparently from what my booking
agent told me so just my europe tour
what has been um your craziest live show
experience or your craziest like groupie
experience you've had overseas
uh definitely not group experience
because i'm i'm a wholesome person
but
maybe a wild fan maybe oh
yeah are you still dating the leblanc
chick
no okay that was a while ago uh i broke
up with her okay she sucks oh [ __ ] her
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
dog [ __ ] dog [ __ ]
um
crazy probably like russia bro like
literally okay so here i'll travel for
tour right like we'll fly we'll do all
this stuff las vegas but like when i'm
flying in russia or anywhere in europe i
won't tell anyone my schedule you just
know where i'm going from the date in my
tour flyer so like we're like we'll pull
up to every city on flight and bro like
200 people at the gate waiting and they
don't know your flight schedule wow i
definitely think that europe nothing
america appreciates music right but
europe appreciates a little more because
we're not able to go there all the time
you ever like russia is a [ __ ] scary
place i love russia but like have you
gone there and like
maybe like i'd be so afraid to get in
trouble in russia bro oh i'm i'm scared
to get anywhere in trouble in europe i
feel like i'm [ __ ] because that
[ __ ] putin is a wild boy oh man
he's lit yeah no it's crazy and then
these these most these kids don't need
to speak they don't speak english mostly
you know a lot of my fans are supported
in in europe and everywhere they can
it's broken but they get but they can
hold a convo with you and they know your
music i mean it's not perfect right but
it's
you can you can go through it
have you been to any uh
brothels in europe
oh man [ __ ] actually i have
nice in russia and so russian brothels
yeah it's lit what are those like
dude so check the story out so literally
after my fest this was um
like maybe like four years ago or three
years ago i tell my uh the festival
owner i want to go to the best strip
club in russia and we're in moscow cool
see that i'm gonna take you we get
somewhere bro it's like bro like the
sketchiest
outside looking place i've ever seen in
my life but there's like 10 rolls royce
outside so i'm like oh [ __ ] like they're
like 10 double log outside sketchy you
walk inside bro like just two big
russian guys like this patting you down
and there's an elevator but the elevator
you can only go up one by one oh
weird so i'm like okay cool so i'm with
two festival owners and two homies that
have yeah so i'm like okay one of you
festival owners go first and i'll go
after so literally one by one going
upstairs so we go upstairs
and i was like yeah i want to go to
strip club but just a bunch of girls and
like martini dresses like and some weird
[ __ ]
and they're holding numbers on top of
their goddamn thing because they were
playing some game i don't [ __ ] know
it was really [ __ ] weird
but after everything they sit down
whorehouse
wow
wait so the girls weren't holding the
numbers so you could be like i want
number two they were no no they're
holding numbers because they're playing
some game with the dj but i didn't
understand the [ __ ] game can i speak
russian did it feel like something like
you know you see these like action
movies like
xxx or something and there's always like
a it's like does it feel like something
like real sketchy like movie type [ __ ]
oh no the minute the minute we got ins
the outside looks sketchy but the minute
we got inside
lit not sketchy at all like everyone was
having fun it was all lit what did the
girl go for that you uh what was the
what was the going rate in russia
the going rate yeah
oh man what was it
i think like
200 bucks right right yeah like 250.
250. yeah 250 usd yeah usds wow how many
did you grab i just won just one yeah
was it was it was it worth the 250 dude
yeah however it's just bad we're still
friends you're friends with the russian
[ __ ] yeah nice when you say still
friends what's that mean oh like you
know it's like so right on the instagram
picture like oh hey how are you doing
like she was cool you got to have a
special kind of uh female fan that like
you know
listen man
i know i've been to your show like i've
been to a couple of your
your shows and smaller venues you got
some pretty wild ass fans that are like
i'm assuming down for a lot of [ __ ] with
you you know what i'm saying oh yeah you
know what i'm i have a motto i
can't do anything with fans so you do
you don't [ __ ] fans i can't that's a
good rule things get weird right um
a lot of things things get weird
um i feel like you also when you do that
you like
okay when someone's a fan of you they're
a friend of everything
the mystery behind you this is this i
feel like when you do that it goes away
they're not they're not a fan anymore
yeah i've already [ __ ] them yeah i
can't that actually makes sense i don't
like it i like girls who like literally
don't know
who i am or don't really know you get me
like
some weird [ __ ] hmm like you know the
[ __ ] i am oh you're gonna find out when
you follow me the russian prostitute
yeah it's cool it's business nice and
then after we just watch tv and eat
ubereat so you let me so you go to this
russian place
they get them playing the game
and it's just a it's a it's a bunch of
girls in martini dresses dude i swear to
god and then they're playing some game i
don't the [ __ ] they're playing then
everyone's just mingling right but we're
in a section yeah and then just are
coming up to us they're like oh where
are you from blah blah blah like your
chain like this and then yeah
and then you just pick your chick and
then they take you to a room
i went back to my hotel oh you took her
to the hotel oh okay okay okay i didn't
they didn't have bedding there i they
might have but i was like ugh i don't
trust it
you might catch bed bugs or something
else yeah yeah
you ever had std never never clean like
a whistle good for you it's been clean
good for you yeah right std of course
yeah no i'm clean i had a
gonorrhea oh [ __ ] yeah curable yeah shot
of penicillin up the ass
literally
72 hours
good
cleared up right back on the scene back
on the scene back in the mix never
happened
yeah no yeah that's hey man shout out to
you man you know for your persona you're
a pretty responsible guy all things
considered yeah you have to be
responsible you get a lot of i mean look
for all the guns and the drugs and the
[ __ ] you'd be posted in your life you
know well shout out florida where all my
guns are good yes all your guns are
legal 100 percent out here it's a
problem yeah i can't have that here yeah
you got some like serious guns how many
guns you own um
i don't know 20 enough probably wow
but every it's floored everything's
legal i have my concealed i have
everything i can walk around everywhere
with it what's the most expensive gun
you own
um
the most expensive gun like the prize
possession in the collection
um
i i what the [ __ ] i think we i have a
tp9 that's like maybe we're like 2600
oh wow that's not that pricey but it's
nice i have some cool guns i have a
cobra mac 11
factory baby blue gun it cost me like
sixteen hundred wow it's like a mac
element like factory baby blue you've
been in florida as long as you've been
have you ever made it over to mike
busey's house no but i've definitely
been invited a bunch of times it's a
while but he looks like he lives in
orlando yeah like middle florida yeah
it's it's uh called the sausage guy you
know there's a place in florida called
the sausage castle the homie mike busey
owns it
i haven't been to the new house but the
old house
was like
insane i've never been we're supposed to
but we had to go [ __ ] pigs and glory
holes and [ __ ] alligators and machine
guns and
strippers ultimate bro house
no but it was like
you know like if you ever been to a have
you ever like been to an insane clown
posse concert never yeah unfortunately i
have
it was like uh
the juggalo version of like the playboy
mansion it was even the girls that was
in there were like
they were cool like you know if you're
into like
you know white chicks who smoke
marlboros yeah
yeah not yeah yeah but it was just a
wild place you gotta yo shout out to
mike busey great guy he just hit me up
uh he he does on veterans day he's got
this lady who comes to the [ __ ]
sausage castle
and it's open invite to anyone who's
ever been in the military and on
veterans day this lady literally stays
at mike busey's house all [ __ ] day
and she sucks everyone's dick
so if you're a veteran you go to my
busy's house on veterans day you get a
blow drop to completion now mind you
there's like a hundred dudes standing
around
in his living room getting their [ __ ]
sucked by this [ __ ] chick i think her
name's like something jizz i don't know
not a looker obviously with that being
said
shout out to the veterans shot this is
only in florida these are florida things
yeah that's where florida's awesome you
can go go get your dick suck you can go
eat wings out of strip club and you can
shoot a machine gun you shoot a machine
you can do anything you literally can do
anything you can go wrestle crocodile if
you want
yeah alligator i forgot which one we
have i think it's alligators some [ __ ]
maybe both yeah you can go wrestle
whenever you want do another [ __ ] one
in florida yeah yeah it's crazy and then
iguanas are everywhere hey go get
gonorrhea and get a penicillin shot
you're good oh
yeah i don't i'm not no more i'm married
now that's my wife shout out to my wife
um what part of florida do you actually
live in miami oh yeah i mean my name is
great man born and raised
what is the best strip club in your
opinion in miami oh man honestly
it's changed over the years but at this
very moment
i have to give it
to gold rush gold rush golder's cabaret
where's that at um where the hell is it
it's like
um
it's like
almost downtown more like toward like
the little haiti area but not in low
haiti i think i could be [ __ ] up i
could be very like the big ones we
always hear about tootsies obviously
booby trap 11. eleven's not really a
strip club i like eleven a lot but i
don't consider eleven to strip because
like everyone else it's like a mega club
even though gold rush and eleven's like
by the same people right mm-hmm it's
literally the same people but i think
ultra super lit and they have awesome
food 11's like a mega club where girls
happen to be stripping yeah it's lit
it's like vegas and i love booby trap on
the river right but it's like it's like
been like bad recently
oh it's been bad yeah like dude like who
was it i think with the online like zoe
dollars like shot at him i think he got
like shot outside of it
oh [ __ ] yeah it was all over twitter
trying to zoe dallas man very
underappreciated south florida
i i respect him hats off to him he's
killing it he got his bulletproof
vehicle business going yeah he's a
[ __ ]
haitian hibachi truck too oh really yeah
he just opened it i haven't been there
by sign poster but have you been doing
any sort of like investments like with
some of the money you got so me and my
homie mikey we just opened up a cookie
company it's called nikki gordon sweet
treats fire so every month we do cookie
drops and we just bought a space that
we're about to open up to the public oh
in south florida in miami that's crazy
i like that name it's like you guys
doing cookie drops like the [ __ ]
supreme dude i swear they sell it like
supreme every month wow for the weekend
sold out and we only do once a month
every month we do new flavors how's like
like um
you know
not being able to maybe tour like you
were before because of the pandemic i
mean i know you're doing all the rolling
louds but are you also going to be
hitting the road solo again yeah so i'm
dropping my my mixtape november 5th
gorgeous busy gordo and then i'm going
to plan a tour around that
nice
your shows are crazy man
yeah well listen man uh that well you
you have some you have a lot of music
out right now yeah you'll be at rolling
loud in new york and la right yeah both
new york and l.a do you just have the
rolling allowed pass now
um i wouldn't say pass like have you
ever not been on rolling loud i've
definitely not been on a few of that
which one um
not the one that just happened to the
one before but the one before that in
miami you weren't on the miami show one
of them but it's because i played one
like back to back to back oh yeah about
to say bro you got like that i dj'd at
the second rolling loud that's where i'm
is that where i met you or am i tripping
i think i met you before that oh
i think the first time it was in tampa
but yeah the second one was the one
where you realized like oh [ __ ] that was
the one that was future in wayne yeah
and it was in wynwood and it was like oh
[ __ ] i remember one word and it was like
yo this is this might be special the
first one was kind of random because it
was raining and [ __ ] yeah
i think schoolboy cube was a headliner
was it i think was bronzing the
headlighting are rich schoolboy q was on
the show
juicy j juicy j was on the show bronson
was there and then the second one was
like future and wayne and i was like oh
this [ __ ] is like this ain't no joke and
then i think after the third one it was
just like oh this is the other show this
is the illustrator right because at the
time there was no um you know we used to
have rock the bells which was a festival
in l.a but it's nothing like but it was
nothing like rolling out loud no not at
all it's like crazy so shout out to
those guys man and shout out to you you
got the you got the uh what's the pass
called at rolling loud the [ __ ] you
passed
i don't have that yet that [ __ ] you pass
is fire i need it just [ __ ] you
but look man i appreciate you uh for
pulling up and looking forward to the tv
[ __ ]
anything else you want to plug go get
you how can they find the [ __ ]
cookies oh [ __ ] gordon sweet treats
it'll be on my instagram the real fan
nick i'll drop it once a month my
mixtape drops november 5th
stay clean stay clean
stay off the [ __ ] stay off the shits and
go to strip clubs and be safe yes get on
that keto cook oh yeah keto it too
this [ __ ] guy